new ideas are fine but they are also
illegal so listen do you mind if i ask a
few questions it shouldn't take much
time
great because we actually have some
place important to beat so if it would
speed things up we're happy to wave our
right to council
wow council the c word
wait wait are you guys in law
enforcement no no no i just i have a
buddy who's a detective in the nypd ooh
i bet he's better than me at getting
people to talk
everything i know about interrogation i
learned from the newlywed game
so look why don't you just eat write
down your answer to these questions
okay question one um what were you gonna
use the guns for
okay and then we'll read them out when
you're done hunting
okay you see i know you boys around the
level okay uh question two
what do you hunt
[Music]
deer grouse and other small fowl oh yep
we hunt
everything you know deer grouse a horse
once yes we love killing
any animal oh i hear you okay
question three uh you said you had
somewhere important to go so
where exactly is that
[Music]
dinner date dinner date that's what mine
says as well sorry about the handwriting
the point is neither of us are lying
should we just pick up our keys on the
way out or how you want to
do this no one has ever
beaten the newlywed game no one
hi we received the call i don't know
anything about that
we were tipped off about a possible
narcotic situation
here pam hey i got this okay hello
officers
dwight schrute former volunteer
sheriff's deputy listen i may have
inside information that someone is
hiding drugs in this very office
just pretend like we're talking until
the cops leave
those are real cops real guns
i wonder what's going on officers i
reveal to you the perpetrator
hey what is this searches things sir can
you step away from your desk please why
sir please step away from your desk hey
what's going on you don't have my
permission to do this
they don't need your permission flanders
and they've got the company's permission
hey hey what are you why are you doing
this uh
you know what i think this i this is
probably misunderstood don't search my
stuff
i have a reasonable right to privacy
save your whining for the jury there
flenderson
yeah let's cancel this okay sir did you
recently return from a trip to central
america oh my
wrong god this out oh gosh that is not
mine
what's going on here no that's i don't
know what that is and
i bet he has nothing to do with that ah
that's mine no michael no it's mine
some basil salad dressing i think
salad dressing yeah it's a caprese salad
it's a little bit of uh mozzarella right
there
are you kidding me it's my salad
so wait a minute there's no drugs no oh
damn it come on
we got a fake tip wait officers are you
sure you don't want to interrogate him
no you have laws that protect you and in
any kind of interrogation why don't you
use them
you must feel pretty good about yourself
right now i didn't put caprese salad in
my drawer michael
did you since when is it illegal to put
caprese salad anywhere hello france hmm
you guys enjoying that cheese it's
unpasteurized ah
what's that mean unpasteurized i don't
care i don't care
technically it's illegal in this country
smuggled it back from paris
the boys in blue ah what can i do for
you
for we got a tip about some food
entering the country illegally
no no no no no no it's just cheese guys
uh i got it in france okay did you
declare it on your customs form when you
re-entered the country
we're gonna need you to come down to the
station i'm sure that's not necessary
let's just this is really good cheese
you should try some are you trying to
bribe us
no oh god i surrender
we've got a couple of customs agents
coming down from the border and they are
not happy i can't believe this
i never break the law i've never even
jaywalked never i mean i
i i everyone does it sometimes you said
that to the charges
well well we got a hit on your prince
seems as you're wanting for tax fraud in
colorado
what i've never even been to colorado i
mean i had a layover in denver once
man you can't keep your story straight
can you come on oh come the customs guys
now
fellas he's all yours
you got to see the stupid look on your
face check this out i'll take a picture
classic you seemed a little uptight
thought we'd have some fun with our new
boss
wow this you got me good one making me
think i was gonna like die in federal
prison
ah that's super funny you scamps
gosh you know everything in here has a
story like
this hole punch okay it's only supposed
to be able to do 18 pages but one day
i got it to do 25. i went straight home
and made love to jerusha that day
well that's a story i'll remember oh
yeah you like it
you should have it oh uh no i oh no come
on please you love it
take it um if he gets a hole punch can i
get this bag full of cash
whoa oh that's my rainy day fun
corporate sets aside a certain amount of
the budget for miscellaneous maintenance
so whenever we don't use it i just take
it out in cash and set it aside you know
just in case
but they think you spent this on
maintenance yeah and i would have
if i needed to but i didn't so just
leave it there for the next manager
so you told them you spent money you
didn't spend
then you took the money and kept it in a
bag hidden in your office
yeah isn't that embezzlement
no embezzlement is when you put jewels
on your jacket
i think you mean bedazzling which is
also a crime
no no b what if it doesn't work hey we
thought of
everything except for an alibi and an
escape route but
we'll figure it out as we go you don't
want to overthink these things kind of
freaking out here
go boy i got you this plan is foolproof
and when it's over we can finally have
the lives we deserve
[Music]
i am a safe installer here to install at
a safe
so just a point to where the guacamole
money is and i'll
install the safe in the how you say
a place
yeah hi we're being robbed
gee down to us man his hat's a golf ball
and he's got a terrible mustache
we need to get married now i do for el
always and forever i do all right
everybody there has been
a lot of name calling against our office
today
corporate maligning slurring much of it
coming from
one of you who claims that
prison is better
than here and none of us can say boo
because none of us have ever been to
prison
well there's somebody i'd like you to
meet
somebody else who has been to prison
who can tell you what it is really
like i'm prison mike
you know why they call me prison mike do
you really expect us to believe you're
somebody else do you really expect me to
not push you up against the wall [ __ ]
all right hey hey hey that's just the
way we talk in the clink
but a lot of fun talk about prison today
but i am here to scare you straight
i am in this gay astronaut
in prison you are somebody's [ __ ]
oh and you you my friend would be
the belle of the ball don't drop the
soap
don't drop the soap michael please
where did you learn all of this internet
so not prison and prison at 50
look prison stinks is what i'm saying
it's not like you can go home
and recharge your batteries and come
back in the morning and be
with your friends having fun in the
office
what'd you do prison mike i stole
and i robbed and i kidnapped
the president's son and held him for
ransom
that is quite the rap sheet prison mike
and i never got caught neither
well you you're in prison but mm-hmm
prison mike
what was the food like in prison gruel
sandwiches gruel omelets nothing but
gruel
plus you can eat your own hair wow
prison sounds horrible yeah yeah well
thank you andy
thanks president mike what's the very
very worst thing about prison
don't encourage him dwight the worst
thing about prison
was that was the dementors they were
flying all over the place and they were
scary and then they come down and they
suck the soul out of your body and it
height
dementors like in harry potter no not
harry potter
there are no movies in prison this is my
point
you guys got it soft and cushy this
place is freaking awesome
the people are awesome your boss is nice
everybody seems to get along
people are tolerant people who have
jumped to conclusions
can redeem themselves nobody's nobody's
[ __ ]
i hope that this scared you and from me
prison mike
to you i just want to thank you for
listening to me
and letting me be a part of your life
today cause you got a good life
you got a good life a good life
you